the eh-2-zed of isms absurdism most
philosophical isms are attempts to make
sense of the world who are we why are we
what's the point and so on but one ism
wastes no time on this topic at all
it's called absurdism in answer to the
question what is the meaning of life
absurdism says there isn't any no
meaning no point no worries life is
pointless existence is meaningless and
look how many peas I have in this pan
absurdism was pioneered by the danish
philosopher sir and Kierkegaard who said
that as the reality of God is beyond
human comprehension it is absurd for
humans to have faith in God in the 20th
century absurdists removed the concept
of God entirely from the equation for
choosing to make meaning and meaningless
Ness an entirely human issue Albert
Camus believed that as life is
meaningless we can have one of two
responses we can end it all or we can
find our own meaning it doesn't matter
you can as one of his characters does
spend your life transferring peas from
one pan to another or you can jump off a
bridge it's all the same thing life is
absurd say the absurdist there is no God
so there is no point but they go on to
say that's fine absurdism is an ism
whose influence has been strong in the
arts the idea that nothing has meaning
is a liberating one particularly in
areas like literature and drama which
have traditionally been all about the
search for meaning most notably
absurdism spawned the theatre of the
absurd probably the only theatrical
movement inspired by philosophy the
theatre of the absurd gave us the French
writer Eugene ionesco whose play
rhinoceros was about the dangers of
conformity and featured a lot of
rhinoceroses the Irish genius Samuel
Beckett whose work is less rhinoceros
based and the British writer
nf Simpson who wasn't really an
absurdist at all but he's very very
funny indeed especially in his absurd
masterpiece a resounding tinkle
Beckett by the way could also be very
serious an ass for Ionesco The Critic
Kenneth Tynan famously once said once
you've seen all of the in esko's plays
you have seen one of them which is
absurd but true just like absurdism
absurdism suits comedy in fact because
the best comedy is essentially absurdist
and perhaps this is why absurdism will
never really go away
you